well it's election day again well it's
groundhog day
again and it seems like every four years
we have the same conversations about the
electoral college because there are a
lot of misconceptions about what the
electoral college is
and why it exists what the problems with
the electoral college are and
what we can possibly do about them
contrary to popular belief
citizens don't actually vote for the
president of the united states directly
and the electoral college is the
electors
that form every four years to actually
vote
for who is going to be the president and
vice president of the united states
the electoral college consists of 538
electors that are divvied up amongst the
states
and in order to win the presidency you
have to receive an absolute majority of
those electoral votes which
at the present time requires 270 votes
in the electoral college
you'll often hear people talk about how
you're not actually voting for the
president of the united states you're
voting for people to vote for
the president of the united states and
is that actually true well we're going
to get into all of that today
[Music]
the basis for the electoral college is
found in article 2 section 1 of the
constitution
it gives each state quote in such manner
as the legislature thereof
may direct electors equal to its
representation in congress
and to eliminate the electoral college
we would need to amend the constitution
however the constitution and the courts
give the state significant leeway to
make changes to
how their electoral college
representatives are chosen and who they
are required to vote for so
let's examine how all of this works the
framework's main concern was that people
wouldn't know who the national
candidates were they'd be familiar with
their local candidates but wouldn't care
about the national candidates so there
needed to be some sort of
intermediary body to make the decisions
about the national candidates
each state has its own process for
picking electors democrats and
republicans at the state level pick
their own slate of electors and
this can happen in early spring or as
late as october when each state
certifies its election results that's
when the winning party slate of electors
is officially chosen
and although i guess you could say it's
an honor to be an elector traditionally
all the electors do is rubber stamp the
election results
electors can be just about anyone bill
clinton was an elector for new york in
2016.
the missouri republican party nominated
a guy in the past who has been convicted
of violence at an abortion clinic
michigan's republicans selected william
rowerdink who engineered a huge
accounting fraud scandal that required
him to pay nearly 300 million dollars in
restitution
in california nancy pelosi's daughter
was an elector and so was dianne
feinstein's granddaughter
like i said it could be just about
anyone but the presidential election is
held every four years on the tuesday
after the first monday
in november in each state electors meet
after the presidential election on the
first monday
after the second wednesday in december
to cast their votes for the president
and vice president in separate ballots
and traditionally it doesn't really
matter who was picked since the electors
are supposed to pledge their vote to
whomever the vote chose
so if new york voters decided they
preferred hometown hero donald trump to
hillary clinton
bill clinton in 2016 would have had to
cast his electoral vote for trump
with obvious exceptions which takes us
to faithless electors
most states use the popular vote results
to decide which party's slate of
electors will be in play
this means that if the state requires
electors to follow the popular vote in
the state and not all states do
then the electors must pledge their vote
to whichever candidate receive the most
votes in that state
and occasionally an elector will assert
their right to vote for any candidate
they want ignoring their party's
candidate
these people are known as faithless
electors and as of now 33 states and the
district of columbia
have laws punishing electors who decide
to do this but
only 15 of these states actually have an
enforcement mechanism to force those
electors to change their vote to whoever
won the popular vote
and before 2016 there were only 157
faithful selectors in american history
but this is becoming a slightly larger
problem as time goes on
in 2016 a few electors in colorado cast
votes instead for colin powell
who was not on the ballot even though
colorado voters selected hillary clinton
in washington state a few electors voted
for colin powell and john kasich
washington state's voters selected
hillary clinton so what were these
faithless electors doing and what were
they hoping to accomplish
well the electors who spoke on the
record said that they wanted to
encourage republicans to pick someone
other than donald trump as president
this is of course problematic given that
the election had already happened and
their state had picked
hillary clinton but the electoral
college had also already been settled
selecting donald trump as president
so this seems as good of a time as any
to pause and talk about some of the
anti-democratic issues inherent in the
electoral college
obviously we've seen several times now
where one candidate has received more
votes than the other candidate on a
national level
yet that candidate loses the
presidential election because of the way
that the
electors and the electoral college are
divvied up now i can already hear
many people saying and typing into the
comments right now
yes but america is not a democracy it is
a republic
and that's true as far as it goes but it
doesn't really answer any of the
questions it's sort of like saying that
the first amendment doesn't protect all
types of speech and that is also true
but it sort of
raises the question without answering
what speech is protected and what speech
isn't protected
and here where you're talking about a
democratic republic or
a republican democracy it's a bit of a
spectrum and
the american system incorporates aspects
of a republic as it does
incorporate aspects of a democracy as
well that doesn't really answer the
question as to
which one is better and in fairness to
those people who argue that america is a
republican
not a democracy to say something is
pro-democratic isn't necessarily
a good thing there are reasons why you
want to incorporate republican
principles
and generally what people mean when they
say something is republican that's
small r republican what they're saying
is that there's an intermediary between
the people who vote and the people that
make the laws so in this case generally
we're talking about congress or
sometimes the state legislatures
but by the same token you can't argue
that small
or republican values and principles are
necessarily
good and in fact some of the reasons why
the united states incorporated some of
those small r republican ideals
into the system of government are no
longer valid or
helpful in this day and age for example
after the presidential election in 1800
which was depicted in the musical
hamilton
after that resulted in a tie between
thomas jefferson and aaron burr
the 12th amendment was ratified in 1804
which
stipulates that each elector must talk
less smile more and
cast a distinct vote for president and
vice president instead of
two votes for president it also requires
a person to receive a majority of the
electoral votes for vice president for
that person to be elected vice president
by the electoral college and arguably
that made the country more democratic
and
less republican but it fixed some of the
unworkable aspects of the original
constitutional system in 1800
and that's just the tip of the political
iceberg of how individuals voting has
shifted in our country
well if it isn't matt from extra credits
what brings you to my side of youtube
will i overheard you talking about the
electoral college and how it hasn't
changed or adapted much since america's
founding wait this video isn't done yet
how did you hear me never mind that
you know it has changed though how we
vote like what americans physically did
throughout our history when we went to
the polls to choose who each state's
electors would support
for instance back in colonial times and
just after the revolution you could
drunkenly declare your vote in public at
a carnival
ah the golden age of voting but by the
1850s most states had expanded the
electorate to the point that voice
voting was impractical
during america's first election in
1788-89
the popular vote totaled only 43 782
but by the election of 1856 the popular
vote was well over 4 million
voting technology had to change to keep
pace so we shifted to paper ballots and
that's when things got really weird like
how the parties used to print their own
ballots not the state
which totally never messed up anything
in fact we made an entire video about
all of this
and more over on the extra credits
channel and once you've finished up here
we'd love for all of you to come check
it out
sounds good to me we'll see you over
there later matt awesome
cool if i just wait here actually i'm
kind of in the middle of this video
so right right right yeah totally no
understood
uh um i i i mean i could just play
phoenix right in the corner until you're
done or
bailiff tackle this man get him out of
my court
he said the thing totally worth it
yeah uh so things got even more
small d democratic in 1913 when the 17th
amendment was ratified
the constitution originally required
state legislators to choose state
senators rather than
voters a very republican principal but
not very democratic
however this became contentious when
state legislatures fought amongst
themselves over who to appoint and
senate seats started going to the
highest bidders the 17th amendment gave
people the right to vote for their
senators
directly instead of the state's
legislatures this is called a direct
election where the people choose who's
in office but america
is still a republic because they have
official senators who
actually vote on the laws themselves but
back to our story
and the electoral college after 2016 the
supreme court ruled in a case called
shuffalo vs washington
the state may enforce an elector's
pledge to support the winning party's
nominee and the state voter's choice for
president
colorado's faithless elector's law
mandated that an elector be removed
immediately the washington state law
required that electors
be fined a thousand dollars if they
contradicted the popular vote of that
state
the supreme court said that this was
acceptable because article 2 includes
only the
instruction to each state to appoint
electors and the 12th amendment only
sets out the elector's voting procedures
the constitution doesn't contain any
language indicating electors have
discretion
so if a state individually says that
there can be no
faithless electors in that state then
that state won't have any faithless
electors and
states can remove these electors on the
spot but sheffield did not
outlaw faithless electors 33 states and
d.c
require electors to vote for a pledged
candidate but most of these states don't
penalize a faithless selector like
washington or colorado
in many of these states the faithless
electors who break his or her pledge
simply get away with it and the deviant
vote is still counted or cast
this includes some of the states where
the 2020 presidential election is
expected to be closest
in florida ohio and nevada electors are
supposed to vote for the candidate who
won the majority of the state's popular
vote
or for the candidate of the party that
nominated that elector
but if they do their own thing then that
vote still counts
and then there are major battleground
states like pennsylvania which actually
don't require electors to support the
winner of the state's popular vote
could that elector change their vote
well under current pennsylvania law
yes but faith of selectors actually
don't come up that often
and fingers crossed so far they've never
been decisive
in a presidential election but there is
one scenario that
hasn't ever been particularly relevant
that may become
important in this particular election
some refer to it as a doomsday scenario
which is that there's actually room for
states to dramatically change how
electors must vote any state legislature
could enact legislation that would
change how the governor
appoints electors and a state
legislature could require that its
electors vote for a candidate who did
not receive a majority of the state's
popular vote
there's no constitutional provision or
federal law that requires electors to
vote according to the results of the
popular vote in that particular state so
if for example a republican legislature
that's
capital r republican in this case in
let's say pennsylvania
decided to change the law right before
the election
to change who the electors vote for
could they
well very possibly and this loophole is
allegedly already being explored by the
trump campaign which is reportedly in
discussions with state and national
republicans to quote
bypass election results and appoint
loyal electors in battleground states
where
republicans hold the legislative
majority and this isn't just a
hypothetical lawrence thomas chair of
the pennsylvania republican party
also told the atlantic that he has
discussed the direct appointment of
electors with the trump campaign saying
quote
i've mentioned it to them and i hope
that they're thinking about it too but
frankly this seems like
an unlikely scenario and if any
political party were successful in
creating such an anti-democratic policy
that we're able to
counter the will of the people and if
that policy were decisive
in a presidential election there would
probably be riots in the streets but
with the current electoral college
system and this
small r republican principle these kind
of scenarios are possible
and states can pass a law changing the
way that electors are chosen because the
supreme court has ruled that the people
have no right to
select the electors themselves so a
state could change the law to take back
the people's right to select the
electors and use
some other policy rather than the
popular vote of that particular state
so let's talk about how these electoral
votes in the electoral college are
apportioned
each state's electoral votes are equal
to the number of representatives and
senators the state has
in congress house seats apportionments
are based on
population and are reapportioned every
decade after the census which is why the
census is so
important every state is guaranteed at
least one seat in the house and then
that number goes up based on the
population
and of course as you remember from
civics class every state has two
and only two seats in the senate so the
constitution specifies how many electors
every state gets it's pretty simple math
the number of senators plus the number
of congress people
but the constitution is silent on just
about everything
else the constitution leaves it up to
the states how they're going to
apportion those electors in the
electoral college and on what basis
states can make the decision as to
whether
to grant all of the electors for that
state or just a portion of them
it's probably not surprising that by the
election of 1800 the states had decided
how they were going to apportion the
electors in the electoral college and
had more or less all shifted to a
winner-take-all system also known as a
first-past-the-post system
because that's how most u.s elections
occurred i'll note parenthetically that
most modern democracies use a
proportional representation system in
their legislature but
that's a can of worms for an entirely
different video now most states have a
winner-take-all system that awards the
votes of the state's electors to the
presidential candidate who obtains the
most votes in that state
maine and nebraska however have enacted
the congressional district method which
allocates one electoral vote to the
winner of the popular vote in each
state-drawn district in winner take all
states which are the vast majority of
american states
all of the electoral votes available to
that state go to the winner of the
popular vote in that particular state so
if a candidate wins a simple majority in
the state then 100
of the electoral votes in that state go
to that candidate regardless
of whether they win with one vote or
with one million votes
and that's how it works in 48 states and
the district of columbia
this is a system that america inherited
from the british that's often referred
to as a first-past-the-post system
but it's important to note that not all
of the framers of the constitution
actually agreed with the winner-take-all
system that the states adopted in the
electoral college and in fact by 1823
james madison the father of the
constitution railed against this
winner-take-all system
he actually argued for a more granular
district-based system if not a national
popular vote in general
and in fact he proposed an amendment to
the constitution to do away with the
construction of the electoral college as
it more or less exists today
but it's received a lot of criticism
because there can often be a lot of
people in the minority of that state
whose votes are effectively uncounted
there are a lot of republicans in
california but effectively they have no
effect on the election because
there will be a majority of democrats
voting in california and all of
california's electoral votes will go to
democrats
there are a lot of democrats in texas
but effectively those votes
aren't counted either because if the
majority vote for
republican in texas then all of texas
electoral votes will go to the
republican candidate
and coupled with the fact that smaller
states receive more electoral votes in
comparison to their population
this is how you can get the scenario
where a candidate receives less of the
popular vote but wins in the electoral
college a lot of people refer to this as
gerrymandering but that's not quite
right gerrymandering refers to
specifically and intentionally uh
creating weird districts to
create a certain outcome and
apportioning the population whereas
this is just an issue that comes up with
the way that the states
exist and there's no way to change the
outline and the borders of the states
themselves and this is just a byproduct
of the fact that it's a winner take all
system in
almost all of the states interestingly
the argument that the electoral college
benefits the small states
and that's the reason it was adopted in
the first place is largely apocryphal
in reality it has more to do with these
southern slave-holding states
wanting to retain power related to the
three-fifths compromise
but since the adoption of the
winner-take-all system small states have
for the most part been ignored unless
they were battleground states which
we'll get to in just a bit but this
raises the question as to why more
states don't do what maine and nebraska
do
well it's partially a prisoner's dilemma
and it's kind of about power
when a swing state awards the maximum
number of electoral college votes to the
statewide winner
it ensures extra attention from
presidential candidates
that's why florida and pennsylvania see
a lot of action from the candidates the
stakes are too high to ignore
the fact that florida could go either
way and that's a lot of electoral
votes that could swing an election for
spectator states the winner-take-all
systems offer maximum power to the
candidate favored by the clear majority
of the state's population
and this also gives the state more
cachet than it would
if it were splitting its votes and
parenthetically that's one of the
reasons why
you always hear presidential candidates
have a stance on things like ethanol
pure
american ethanol because corn which is
the product that leads to ethanol
is really big in iowa where there is an
early caucus
and there is a lot of attention paid to
uh campaigning
in iowa and winning the votes of iowans
even though
it's a very low population state but
let's talk about this over
representation of less populous states
america has always tried to thread the
needle between
trying to give every citizen an equal
vote
the idea of one person one vote while
also
trying to create a system of checks and
balances that doesn't let more
populous states completely dominate all
of the other states or
originally the colonies and one of the
features or one of the bugs of the
electoral college depending on who you
ask
is that it's supposed to guarantee that
the populist states can't dominate in an
election but
that also creates a disparity in
representation because we have to go
back to
remembering that the way that the
electoral college is set up is that
every state gets at least three votes
one based on a representative because
the minimum number of representatives in
the
house is one and every state gets two
senators and that's the same regardless
of the population of the state
but when you take the population of the
state and then divide it by the number
of electors
what you get is a wildly different
number so while california has one
electoral
vote per 712 000 people wyoming the
state with the fewest people in the
country
has one electoral vote per 195 000
people
and that's because each state must have
at least three electoral votes so
wyoming has three electoral votes and
only 532 000 citizens
california is the most misrepresented
state in the electoral college
california is home to 12 percent of all
americans but has just 10
of the electoral votes and while that
might not seem like much when you spread
that effect out throughout the entire
country you can get
wildly disparate results and although
california has gained electoral votes as
its population has increased
and it's been allocated more
representatives this hasn't been enough
to address this disparity because
population growth tends to outpace
electoral college representation
which changes once every 10 years when
the census rolls around
even after the census a state doesn't
earn new electoral votes until it's
gained approximately 700 000 new
residents
the result is that a state or
metropolitan area can add hundreds of
thousands of new votes
without gaining any greater electoral
college representation and this is
exactly what's happening in both texas
and california they can add
640 000 new residents which is actually
more than the entire population of
wyoming
and still not gain a single additional
electoral vote
in fact 640 000 is more than the total
voting population of
six of the smaller less populous states
as a result the electoral college tends
to penalize population centers and in a
weird quirk of fate
population centers tend to be pretty
blue while rural communities tend to be
pretty red
but there's no reason why that's
necessarily the case
of course it would be foolish not to
acknowledge the partisan implications
of the electoral college this issue has
turned partisan because the same party
has benefited twice the republicans
and the same party has been
disadvantaged twice hillary clinton won
the popular vote by almost 3 million
votes and al gore won the popular vote
by almost half a million votes
now if demographic changes continue in
the direction that they're going
texas will eventually turn blue and if
that happens republicans would
effectively have no path to ever win the
presidency
ironically due to the electoral college
so for those supporters of the electoral
college ask yourself if you would still
support it
if it precluded republicans from ever
getting the presidency or
at a bare minimum allowing texas to
decide the fate of effectively every
presidential election for the
foreseeable future
and this leads to what people often
refer to as spectator states
although some people claim that the
electoral college protects rural voters
or rural states
this is only partially true presidential
campaigns
still don't tend to make stops in
wyoming north or south dakota or montana
so generally speaking the electoral
college tends to create a disparity in
campaigning between
spectator states and swing states in
2016 for example
most of the presidential campaigns took
place in just four states ohio florida
pennsylvania and north carolina
while two-thirds of the campaign events
took place in just six states
the election was decided by the votes of
around 80 000 people in three states
and the two most populated states
california and texas
are spectator states as are 12 of the 13
least populous
states these states are ignored because
the outcomes are already determined
since the vast majority of voters in
those states prefer
one political party the swing states are
swing states because
they have the most even split between
republicans and democratic voters
and this leads to some weird outcomes
because 48 states in washington dc award
their votes on a winner-take-all basis
which means that
it's possible for a candidate to win the
presidency with around 23 percent of the
national popular vote
and that may not happen in 2020 but the
fact that it can happen
is always alarming and of course in 2016
hillary clinton got over 2 million more
votes than donald trump but lost the
electoral college
306 to 232. in raw votes it was the
largest popular vote lead in history for
a candidate who lost the election
if donald trump wins in 2020 it could be
the first time in american history that
a president was elected twice
without winning the majority of the vote
in either case
so let's talk about some of the
proposals that people have suggested to
fix some of the flaws of the electoral
college
in the current electoral college system
the presidency is awarded to the
candidate who wins at least 270 of the
538 available electoral votes
the constitution gives state
legislatures the right to choose how
presidential electors are
chosen since the 19th century each state
with the exceptions of maine and
nebraska of course
have awarded the electoral votes the
winner of the popular vote in that state
but some people have proposed what's
called the national popular vote compact
and under a national popular vote system
states would commit to award their
electoral votes the winner of the
national popular vote
instead of the state popular vote the
national popular vote compact has been
passed by 15 states and the district of
columbia
and since there isn't a constitutional
requirement as to how these votes are
allocated
so long as these states agree to this
system then
it's constitutional it doesn't require
an additional constitutional amendment
of course a lot of people would be
worried if a individual state decided to
allocate its votes based on the national
popular vote without other states going
along with it or
if a state decided to award its electors
in proportion to
the proportion of the national popular
vote which
is one of the genius aspects of the
national popular vote compact
which is that it would only go into
effect when states controlling at least
270 electoral votes
have joined in the election after that
threshold is reached the national
popular vote states would ensure that
the winner of the national popular vote
became president while the compact would
not abolish the electoral college it
would guarantee that the winner of the
electoral college vote
and the popular vote are the same now
there are certainly some advantages to
having an electoral college but all this
plotting underlies the main problem with
the electoral college which is that
there are a lot of steps that lead to
litigation and mess rather than a clear
winner and
winners that can lose the national
popular vote
the electoral college creates the
possibility of a 269 269 thai
vote the possibility of a 23 vote getter
becoming president
and the possibility of the majority
being ruled by a minority
but i will leave it to you do you agree
with my analysis do you think that the
electoral college is a good thing should
it be abolished
changed or just left alone leave your
objections in the comments and check out
extra credits video on the history of
voting in this country it's
really great where i have a cameo and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other
real law reviews where i talk about the
important legal issues of the day
including lots of stuff about this
election so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court